it's an absolute pleasure to present
tonight's awards in the category of
narrative filmmaking in this category
I'm happy to see that the Academy has
found a full complement of three winning
films to honor let's begin by
introducing you to a bronze medal winner
it was made at New York University where
filmmaker Brendan bellomo created his
entry titled boheme abat this film is a
sci-fi thriller with some incredible
visual effects and in this tale of the
future boheme abat a cyborg soldier
saves himself an a young orphan captive
by making a hair-raising escape from the
captors please welcome this year's
Bronze Award winner Brendan bellomo
hello I've always wanted to thank the
academy and now I have the chance so i
would like to start by thanking the
Academy it's been a wonderful week here
I think all of us have really enjoyed it
and I'd like to thank ASC
cinematographers as well as the writers
at the wga it's been amazing amazing
time here great time to meet people in
network and get some fantastic advice
from other filmmakers in the industry
and I'd like to thank also the Board of
Governors and of course the Academy
again so I like to start by thanking my
fantastic professors and teachers at New
York University and among them my mentor
John Kane maker the head of the
animation program Ezra Sachs the head of
the writing Department and of course Ron
sat off the head of the film scoring
program and Barbara Melman for all their
tremendous support at my stay at NYU I
think all of us have all had amazing
teachers and these ones have really
touched me and influenced my filmmaking
I'd also like to thank my amazing cast
because that's why we make films so that
people can live on the screen everything
else is just to make that happen among
them davis hall the plays boheme bought
wesley Oh Mary who plays the boys ebbed
row his sister Tila played by nadine
jacobson and also t sahara mere who
plays his wife and don castro blaze the
guard amazing working with them i'd like
to thank my
all volunteer crew and cast of over 200
people I'd like to list everybody off
not going to do it but I would like to
thank a couple people who are here
tonight Mike ms Lynn my cinematographer
and Edward goin my production designer
amazing people to work with and who I've
started a collaboration with I know that
will last many many many years finally
like to thank my friends and my family
including my mom and dad for their
amazing support throughout the
production and I grew up with an
animation studio in my basement and
that's still pretty much the case i'd
like to thank my dad Victor bellomo who
composed the harp music as well the
executive producers for the film were
robbing Chesler his wife and my dad
viktor blom oh so dad thanks for all of
your filmmaking support and thank you
again it's an honor
you